*Gun Shot*
[Bird caws]
Oh jeez...
*Shuffling*
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier,
and welcome to Torpor.
Now this game is supposed to be a narrative experience,
or maybe not even narrative
It's about
*Inhale*
the story of a soldier,
who I'm assuming-
Oh.. Hi.
What in the world?
woooahhh...
It's about a soldier who was just shot
and either his life is flashing before is eyes
or,
*Click*
I don't know something I have no idea
[Thud]
I-I'm going into this pretty blind s-..
whyyyy is there a baby crib there?
*Creaking*
This is unsettling.
This is just weird, it's jarring,
because I just got in the game
and as soon as I load it up
Bang!
we're here.
What is this?
I mean obviously it's someone's home
and they had a loving family.
I'm assuming, cause this is a game about a, soldier
getting shot it's gonna be sad I bet.
And it seems to be like World War II era,
If I'm not entirely mistaken, but...
(Mumbling) You know that's all I'm saying that all sounds great.
*Creaky steps*
*Footsteps*
Hello?
Hi!
Also! I ne- I never even realized how weird it was that the soldier had the teddy bear with him.
at the time of his de- Oh?...
*Inhale*
Oh these things trigger meh- OHhh!...
*Train toots*
Oh, so the things with the weird glows around em' trigger memories
Where am I?
Hellooo?
Eugh.
This is creepy
I- I don't even know if this game was supposed to be creepy!
Oh jeez, Ahhg..can't get on there, not allowed.
Okay.
So...
What is happening?
It's just so oddly bizarre.
I mean, when I went into this, I was assuming it was gonna be a sad experience but- I can't go this way either!
Well which way am I supposed to go?
What am I supposed to do?
Oh, oh that was glowing! I didn't even realize that.
That is so cool.
*Loud wind blowing*
Woah.
*Explosion*
Oh!
I'm in the sky!
Oh, I'm a paratrooper.
I'm- I'm- Shit's about to go down!
Holy shit.
So this is like, reliving moments of his life that lead up to his death?
Then he- in that house, there was more than one thing I could have clicked on.
Thasso weird.
Oop, time to go apparently.
*Gun Shot*
Back here?
What?
I guess that led up to the moment immediately before his death, but not...
Not the right moment that I'm looking for though.
Oh that's so cool!
*Thud*
You're searching through his memories until you get to the right place!
Or least that's what I assume it is. I'm not a 100% sure, but,
it could be.
Is there a glow on that?
No, but there was a glow on the jacket in here.
Yeah.
That's so weird.
Oh.
OH!
*Unidentifiable Click*
Woah.
Oh.
Is the only thing in here that teddy bear?
Could there maybe something else hidden in the pews?
Probably not.
Oh, that's so weird.
It's just like... wha- what's fascinating about this game is the jarring transitions of it.
The,
immediate snap, back and forth through realities.
There must be something else that I haven't touched.
Must be a few things.
Man, straight to the funeral.
Man, someone was trying to write a lot of letters.
Wait the suitcase is gone now?
So could be other things here?
Or maybe I'm just gonna be stuck in limbo in this area forever and ever.
Nah, I refuse to believe that. There's gotta be something here.
Ahh, here we go.
Eugh.
This is a bad connotation if it's a bottle of pills.
But here we go...
Eugh.
Ahh, therapy. Oh, oh that's- that's fun. Ugh, yup.
That's not fun.
That was a thing, I'm gonna get back to that, I didn't realize it was a thing before I clicked on it ok.
*Click* (x2)
There we go. Where are we going?
Oh man. Well I know what the guns do, I don't wanna touch the guns!
Oh man!
It's literally nothing but guns!
That's not good! I uh- I know what every single one of those go to!
Oh no.
There's a-
There's bills there, probably just leads back to this room except with LESS GUN!
How about the box of tissues?
No.
Just a bunch of GUN!
It's all GUN!
*sighs* Jesu-
Alright, I'm gonna try the pills.
*Clicking*
Oh are these not... these aren't working anymore! Huh! The pills don't work anymore.
Gun it is, then!
*Gun Shot*
*Bird Caws*
Yep!
Oh, I thought I was gonna come back here.
*Soldier's Body Thuds*
Damn.
It's so bizarre.
So bizarre!
So weird.
So is there anything else in here that I've missed?
The pills are gone...
The jacket's still there...
Why is the jacket still there?
Unless I didn't find what I was looking for in there.
The only reason these would still be here, is to find something else, right?
Can't go around the casket.
I can't click on that.
So there's gotta be something else besides the bear.
*sigh*
I don't see anything else, so I'm assuming-
Man it's gotta be something else.
Oh, the pills are back! That's- wha- Wait, those are gone, but now the pills are back.
But now the suitcase is in that room, why is that in there? Why are the pills back?
Is this gonna lead to something new?
No, it's the same thing!
It's the same dang thing!
*Clicking*
Is this just a loop?
*click*
I gotta find out more about this, maybe I'm doing something wrong here.
Oh!
Oh.
Oh my god, okay.
I-
*chuckles*
I guess that's it! I- It says that I'm...
There's all the paths, and,
it shows like the timeline of everything going through and where everything leads.
I don't know why I expected there to be an ending to this,
considering that it started at the end of this soldier's life.
I guess that's the end!
Man, that's- th- that's weird and... actually quite profound,
because it's like one of those situations where I don't want to accept the end...
But it is what it is....
The guy's dead.
What more is there to say?
There's little bits and storytelling in the environment itself, like,
why was therapy there?
Is that the grieving widow?
Did they go to therapy together because their marriage wasn't working?
Why was there a baby crib there?
Like,
Why was no one at the funeral?
Why did he have the teddy bear with him...
While he was going there?
Maybe the child died...
And he took that teddy bear with him to war,
I have no idea. There are a lot of things open to interpretation,
and I don't think anyone's going to be satisfied with one particular answer.
But as far as a narrative experience that has absolutely no talking besides my own,
*Inhale*
That was fascinating.
That was really fascinating.
I feel like it could be fleshed out more, though.
I feel like it has just very shallow depth,
you know...
the storytelling here but there's-
in this style?
I like it a lot.
I like this story- storytelling style.
This is really cool, so...
Thank you developers for making the game and thank you everybody for watching.
I hope to see more stuff like this in the near future
because it's so interesting to just try to...
go through the environment and seek out clues on your own. And...
build a story from your own imagination so
either way, thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always, I will see *you* in the next video.
Buh bye!